good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight gas prices are up and
you're seeing some stories about it in
the media but what's interesting is how
the press cover rising gas prices
if you look carefully it's pretty clear
they're not that interested in the topic
they just don't find it compelling in
fact they may be a little bored by it
and that shouldn't surprise you there's
no greater divide in american life than
the gap between people who care about
what gas costs and the people who don't
care
it's a cultural divide obviously a chasm
of class economics and geography those
who take uber versus those who drive
their own cars
but it's also deeper than that on some
level the divide is about usefulness
split the country into two groups people
who worry about the price of gasoline
and people who worry about the fact that
gasoline is still legal and ask yourself
which of these groups is more important
to the functioning of the united states
hmm let's see on one side you've got
lawyers hr directors executives at
climate change non-profits gender
studies administrators finance moguls
brain-dead senators columnist for the
atlantic magazine highly paid netflix
producers like michelle and barack obama
and yes prime time cable news anchors
this would be the grifter class they do
little but they benefit greatly as a
practical matter they are useless they
have no skills
most of the time they're a drain on the
actual economy and poison to the culture
the rest of us might be happier and more
prosperous if they become truck drivers
or move to paraguay
that's true and on some level everyone
knows it's true and because it is true
that's why these very same people spend
so much time screaming about how
essential they are because it's so
obvious that they aren't
things worked perfectly well before we
had hr departments
on the other side of the gas price
divide you have everybody else and this
group includes the people who possess
about 95 of the relevant skills you
would need to keep a civilization going
you lose these people and it's the dark
ages literally dark your power grid
shuts down
as it happens these are the very people
who've noticed and winced as the price
of filling a tank has shot skyward over
the past year these are the people being
hurt by rising gas prices the ones who
deserve it the least
the most galling part of all of it is
none of this is an accident america has
more than enough energy to keep gas
prices low
so why is it happening well it's being
done on purpose by the party that hates
gasoline
gas engines are bad for the climate
democrats tell us they appear to believe
that but they also understand something
else about gas
cars mean autonomy if you've got a car
you can go wherever you want the central
planners cannot control you they hate
that
at this point they can't express a
thought like that out loud because it's
too scary so instead they call you a
racist watch
for years you all have continued to
promote fossil fuels despite knowing
that promoting them means promoting
environmental racism and violence in
black and brown communities you all are
still promoting and selling fossil fuels
that are killing millions of people this
is a striking example of white supremacy
so fossil fuels are a quote striking
example of white supremacy that's the
latest thought bubble from prominent
democratic party intellectual
congresswoman corey bush of st louis you
got to wonder what the world's many
non-white opec countries think of that
they must be thoroughly confused by it
but corey bush doesn't know it she's
never heard of opec she just prattles on
thoughtless little [ __ ] that she is
denouncing this or that as a striking
example of white supremacy
that's what she does
what's interesting is that not a single
prominent democrat will tell corey bush
to shut up and sit down they're not
allowed to do that so over time cory
bush's ravings become official
government policy why shouldn't we shut
down energy pipelines in the middle of
an energy crisis pipelines are racist
and having done that which in fact they
are now doing at this moment
why wouldn't we shut down the energy
companies themselves
if energy is racist so are the
corporations that sell it so burn it all
down and make way for utopia
that's what they're concluding
here's a top biden nominee someone who
could very soon supervise every
financial institution in the country
explaining that we should root for the
destruction of the most robust economic
sector in the united states watch
for certain
troubled industries and firms that are
in transitioning and here what i'm
thinking about is primarily coal
industry and oil and gas industry a lot
of the smaller players in that industry
are
uh going to probably uh go bankrupt in
in short order at least we want them to
go bankrupt if we want to tackle climate
change right
we should want them to go bankrupt quote
who's she talking about well she's
talking with the people who make it
possible to have say airplanes asphalt
automobiles farm equipment fertilizer
steel plastics golf balls antihistamines
aspirin soap electricity virtually every
other feature of modern civilization
comes from fossil fuels
but let's just shut them all down and
then applaud as we do the future will be
much better than we promise
that's what the democratic party is as
of tonight so you can see very clearly
why they're not too concerned by the
fact you're going broke filling up your
car going broke is the whole point of
the exercise
here's joe biden's new commerce
secretary gina raimondo
if you were still governor of rhode
island i understand you're not would you
be hoping or asking for the president to
open up the strategic petroleum reserve
again i think it's premature to say what
i would be saying to the president is i
would i would just ask him to keep doing
what he's doing
yeah just keep doing what you're doing
joe biden crushing the middle class with
completely out of control energy costs
if we can hike gas but under 20 bucks a
tank or make it impossible for you to
heat your home in january we'll have one
a desperate population will welcome
whatever we give them next that's what
they're thinking
watch the president's flak from last
month before she disappeared explain
that shut up stop your winding we've got
bigger problems than your household
budget
the climate crisis uh one of the
greatest national security crises the
president sees a number of other world
leaders agree on that front certainly we
all want to keep gasoline prices low
but the threat of the crisis the climate
crisis certainly can't wait any longer
yeah we just can't wait any longer says
the single most entitled person in the
district of columbia nothing's more
important than quote the climate crisis
and of course she's saying that because
it's easy for her to say but what if you
wanted to drive your kids to school for
less than five dollars a gallon what if
you just realized you actually can't
take that family trip to yellowstone
next summer because you can't afford it
anymore
well the sunfire just co-eds like gen
saki these are not real concerns there's
more bitching from a peasant class that
doesn't understand what's good for them
in the end they'll accept it they'll
have to just as they'll have to accept
inflation as a permanent feature of the
american economy which by the way news
flash it is yes inflation's real it's
not transitory like they told us
here's one way to describe what that
means according to the official numbers
unless you got a 6.2 pay raise this year
and you probably didn't but let's say
you did
you lost money
thanks to inflation you got a pay cut
because that's how
much inflation has risen you sell around
you price of a hamburger up by nearly a
dollar a pound of bacon goes from 570 to
seven bucks etc etc etc across every
class of consumer products and real
estate is far worse than that try to buy
a house try to buy used car
bottom line economists have not measured
inflation like what we're seeing now in
decades so the question is why is it
happening
lots of obfuscation on that question but
it's pretty obvious
like rising energy prices inflation is
not an act of god we have inflation
because the geniuses in charge have put
too much money into circulation it is
that simple the more us dollars floating
around the less those dollars are worth
that's the whole story anyone can
understand it
larry summers is the former treasury
secretary he spelled it out back in
february when joe biden's last trillion
dollar spending bill passed watch
i think there's a real possibility that
within the year we're going to be
dealing with the most serious
incipient inflation problem that we have
faced in the last 40 years
that doesn't sound good they wanted to
ignore him but he can't it's larry
summers he ran harvard he's a little
democrat can't just blow him off so
instead the white house attacked him joe
biden's chief economic adviser jared
bernstein declared that larry summers
was quote flat out wrong
so with that settled flat out wrong the
administration just kept printing money
how much
well according to numbers from the
federal reserve between march of 2020
and last month the total amount of u.s
dollars increased by
36 percent
36 percent it's hard to find a precedent
for that
a moment ago we told you the official
inflation rate was just over six percent
6.2
but if the money supply has increased by
36 percent can that really be true do
the math no of course it's not true
and every sophisticated person knows
that it's not true the actual inflation
rate is much much higher than 6.2
percent why do you think so many rich
people are buying cryptocurrency because
they know what inflation means why are
equities up so high inflation
and by the way not to wreck your night
we'll stop after this but consider one
last number if you count just the us
dollars in active circulation and
sitting in checking accounts
our money supply has increased by 336
percent in the last year and a half
is that sustainable come on no it's not
look at the effects of it inflation is
not spread evenly across the country
notice the coastal areas on the map
that's where the biden voters live those
areas are yellow that means less
inflation for them but the middle of the
country bright red that means costs are
going up much faster there that means
the people who can least afford it are
getting hit the hardest
what's that look like in political terms
well this is what it looks like a total
of 23 states have official inflation
rates over six and a half percent of
those 23 18 of them voted for donald
trump in the last election wonder why
the white house isn't worried about
inflation that's why
here's joe biden's chief of staff
explaining that actually
if we want to beat inflation what we
really need to do is print a lot more
money
the buildback better bill is the best
answer we have to bring those costs down
by the way it also does it without
adding a penny to the federal debt it's
fully paid for and without raising a
penny of taxes on families making less
than 400 000 a year
has there ever been a stupider person
that's a metaphysical question we can't
answer it within the confines of a cable
news show but just assess
the text of what he said the
administration boasts it will spend
1.75 trillion dollars and will do so
without raising taxes how do you do that
it sounds like magic well here's how
they do it they print the money out of
nothing
that means
1.75 trillion new dollars dumped into
the system
that new money dilutes the value of
every existing dollar very much
including the dollars you own because
you earned them that's called inflation
can it go on forever well there's a
limit to how long any government can do
this at some point maybe sooner than you
think the currency collapses the build
back better people will have wrecked the
u.s dollar and that will be their
crowning achievement hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else